hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday April 11th table I won't 2016
what's going on how are you it's it's
Sunday night it's a Sunday evening I'm
in the house all by myself
the lovely Nia had some business meeting
or some [ __ ] she had to go to it's show
business I know what you saying you guys
all live in the normal world you're
thinking like wait my wife says she's
got a business meeting on a Sunday night
and [ __ ] yes sir past a certain hour
that means she's out there back I know
that's what you think it but uh I'm in
show business so it's totally normal for
them to go out that way what the [ __ ]
happened to the high-hat over here I
told you got me a little [ __ ]
practice set up there what the [ __ ] is
maybe Cleo was playing it when I wasn't
here anyways anyway Shh
yeah so she's out so I'm gonna try to
knock this out cuz I gotta be at work on
Monday for something for some reason I
still can't say whether what it is or
what's going on hopefully so yep you
know what it is you know what it is
maybe you don't know what it is maybe
you don't listen every week but you know
what it is so I got to be at work on
Monday and Oh Billy [ __ ] clean-living
ever since I got back from Canada Oh
Canada
you bunch of freezin [ __ ] I got just
got back from there and I kind of
realized that when I go on the road with
the fellas we act like we're on some
sort of bachelor party I don't know what
it is - the [ __ ] who is everything
else we basically you know we booze and
we smoke cigars and that thing and it's
just yeah it takes a lot out of me and I
got a bunch of [ __ ] I got to do so I
kind of need to be clear-headed as
opposed to the usual you know usually
when I got nothing going on in my life I
mean I can [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna have
us you right I can wake up the next
morning
right I can be in that mindset but as of
right now I can't so I have not done
anything haven't done [ __ ]
I haven't [ __ ] to have a drank I
haven't smoked I'm eating pretty good
I'm even laying off the internet porn I
mean it's just [ __ ] over actually got
this Time magazine that was about
internet porn and how it's like [ __ ]
people up you know especially like kids
you know when they first like just the
shitty the shoe skidding hope this [ __ ]
you can see on the [ __ ] Internet I
can't believe nobody stepped in
I'm not saying somebody should step in
but um you know I got to tell you if if
they knew what the [ __ ] the internet was
gonna be when it was whenever Al Gore
was inventing it back in the 80s I never
said that I said that I was at I was
involved in the email chain whatever the
[ __ ] he said that [ __ ] guy number one
his campaign was over my money was
dancing around and all sweaty and all
that [ __ ] and he just looked like he was
so [ __ ] relieved that it was over
what a thing to go through running for
president I just saw a clip of Hillary
Clinton I have not been paying attention
at all but Jesus Christ what the [ __ ]
happened to her she looks like Earl
[ __ ] waver
she's like Earl Weaver she was doing
something right she was standing in some
black church right Baptist Church I'm
gonna assume you know I don't think it
was a Jewish synagogue there whatever
the [ __ ] they could temple she's in this
green suit she's just like yelling oh
[ __ ] she was gonna do that's the only
time a politician goes near the black
community is when they're running they
they [ __ ] they swing by the church
they make a whole bunch of promises and
then they get in the [ __ ] limo and
they go let's get right [ __ ] out of
Dodge
and they go over they do a town meeting
talked to all the lunch-pail Lewis right
does any of it says even those people
left in this country if you [ __ ] make
anything and they get over there and
they say roll up their sleeves that's
when you know they're talking to the
work
they take off their sport coat and they
roll up their sleeves you know like
they're gonna build something rather
than just go out there and say the exact
same [ __ ] they just said the Baptist
Church with the more of a [ __ ] lunch
pail sling do it right and the whole
[ __ ] thing it's just gross
I don't know anybody sits there and
watch that [ __ ] but um the latest thing
that I've become fascinated with is I
completely leave whatever the [ __ ] I was
just talking about I'll come back to it
the clean living thing was listen about
clean living it's the most boring [ __ ]
ever
you know anyways I become fascinated
with how super-rich people avoid paying
taxes she's [ __ ] fascinating it's one
of those things you know it's like you
gotta respect it on a certain level it's
the brilliance of it and then there's a
certain level of balls that that takes
because you're [ __ ] with your freedom
anytime you're [ __ ] with taxes you
know what I mean
[ __ ] with the government anytime you
doing that I mean you know why is it I
don't know what the [ __ ] is that a
federal thing I guess if you're not
paying your federal income tax yet bill
that would probably be a federal crime I
don't know I always say you gotta cross
state borders do you have to like not
pay taxes and then leave your state
before it becomes federal I don't know I
don't know these things but anyways just
the balls that it takes and the I don't
know I don't like people physically
hurting other people that type of crime
but when there's something like robbing
banks or tax evasion or even a good
old-fashioned [ __ ] scam if there's
like a like an amazing level of thought
behind it on some level you gotta
respect it I think you know what I mean
like I remember a long time ago there
was some [ __ ] guy he figured out how
to rob parking meters and they were
allegedly it was impossible to do so
this guy figured out how to [ __ ] do
it it's amazing and he did this [ __ ]
this is back
like the 80s or some [ __ ] this guy
figured out how to do it so it was way
way way easier to not have everybody
breathing down your [ __ ] throat you
know people be having eggs watching you
[ __ ] robbing a parking meter
they didn't have a [ __ ] smartphone on
them they'd just be sitting there going
this [ __ ] guy guy just is that guy
robbing a parking meter oh [ __ ]
do you see that anybody see that that
was it that's all that [ __ ] happened
rather than some douche [ __ ] and they're
filming you and you're arrested before
you even get home right and then the
[ __ ] local newscasters they always
got to do some sort of [ __ ] bad pun
you know what I mean
I'll tell you this guy's life his
freedom is now gonna change you know
they do that somehow they get away with
that and like [ __ ] newspapers like
they can have the biggest [ __ ] puns
ever and everybody thinks it's great
you know I don't know I I can't even
think of one right now yeah but whatever
you know you sit at home and you think
about you said you have [ __ ] cubicle
instead of doing your goddamn work you
think of one so anyways this [ __ ] guy
figured out how to do this [ __ ] and of
course the parking meter gods were
beside themselves you know what I mean
it was like one of those sci-fi movies
or like the Titanic movie land not even
God can sink it that's what they were
like not even God could get the [ __ ]
quarters out of this meter this man
right that's they were talking all kinds
of [ __ ] so this [ __ ] guy figured out
how to do it and you're thinking like a
high whatever man you throw what the
[ __ ] you're gonna do with that will do
there's [ __ ] meters all over the city
so this guy anytime he wanted to drink
if he wanted a [ __ ] sandwich is he
his guy he had it perfect it was like
his own ATM machine before ATM machines
he just walked up bing-bang-boom he had
a sack of [ __ ] quarters you go down
to the bank you guys kind of get was on
the Rolly [ __ ] things there right
yeah sure they don't give a [ __ ] nobody
gave a [ __ ] back then nobody was paying
attention they were trying to pay
attention but not not to that type of
[ __ ] this guy would roll the [ __ ]
quarters
you know rose enough quarters
you know he gets himself out how the
[ __ ] would you get all those quarters
down to a car dealership I have no
[ __ ] idea
although I talked to some drug dealers
about how they [ __ ] or a guy who knew
drug dealers let's be honest a pill
let's not act like that news guy saying
that you were in the war and then you
were in a chopper or some [ __ ] next to
the chopper and he didn't really [ __ ]
see it okay
you took a [ __ ] helicopter tour one
time you weren't even in Iraq whatever
the [ __ ] he said I don't pay attention
to [ __ ] so anyways I was talking this
guy basically how back in the day when
drug dealers were still driving around
in flashy cars because from what I heard
nowadays they they don't want to attract
that level of attention how it used to
be was anything any cash deal that was
over ten grand grand had to be [ __ ]
reported so what these drug dealers
would do was they would go out and they
buy a car worth nine grand for cash and
then they driving around for like a
[ __ ] week and then they trade it in
for a car worth 16 grand maybe get seven
for theirs and then they throw another
[ __ ] nine at the other car now they
got a sixteen thousand dollar car you
drive around for a little bit you
[ __ ] trading in another twenty three
thousand dollar car they give you fifth
whatever and so on and so forth until
you trade your way all the way up to
whatever [ __ ] car you wanted and just
I just look at that [ __ ] it's like I
mean that's not the deepest thing but
that's the way my brain would be work
I'd be like whoa you're so got to drive
a piece of [ __ ] then what's the point of
dealing drugs right or I just say [ __ ]
it I'm buying a Ferrari and I'm gonna
drive it until they catch me [ __ ]
three weeks later by the way the Ferrari
I like is the Ferrari California that's
the old man won the [ __ ] GT the Grand
Touring won right I don't know you ride
around in some Batmobile just give me
one that's shaped like a [ __ ] Jaguar
from back in the day you know or maybe a
Toyota Supra
those [ __ ] things from the 80s else
guy loaned me his well he used my truck
to move and I bran and I'd beat the [ __ ]
out of his car and he beat the [ __ ] out
of my truck and we both got our cars
back and he's smelling rubber and I'm
seeing all kinds of scratches all over
my truck and we
it's kind of a fair deal right then we
both got arrested for drinking and
driving months later but that's a
completely different story I enough I'm
all over the map I'm doing this late
night and I don't want to be doing it
right now but I got [ __ ] to do in the
morning so anyways his [ __ ] guy you
know if he had half a [ __ ] brain what
you do is you keep your day job right
keep your [ __ ] day job and then you
know for anything miscellaneous she gets
to go to the parking meters right and
what you do is you start storing up on
the quarters then every once in a while
right you just start you start washing
the money with you [ __ ] cat I know
what you doing you [ __ ] you're going
to stores and stuff yeah well gets a
[ __ ] right you just use it to get
yourself a better TV but what does this
dope do he gets [ __ ] greedy I don't
remember a [ __ ] story goes all I know
is he just started hitting every [ __ ]
goddamn parking meter around and next
thing you know he's sitting on like a
[ __ ] two million dollars in quarters
and he ended up getting busted but there
was a part of it I like the guy
you know so anyways this gets me to the
super rich on out you know but all those
that [ __ ] about the Panama papers and
all that type of stuff I was talking to
another friend of mine who's a [ __ ]
lawyer and I was like how does that work
like how do you get your money out of
the country and then once it's out of
the country how do you make sure nobody
steals it like what happened to Johnny
Depp's character and Blow and then once
you have it out of the country how do
you get it back in without just getting
taxed all over again a busted and he
said basically this is it and he broke
the whole [ __ ] thing down alright or
as far as I know he broke an aspect of
it death I know all you guys are sitting
right now gonna OG she's gonna try to
explain him I'm gonna try to explain
some [ __ ] that was just explained to me
and I don't really know what the [ __ ]
I'm talkin about so let's get rid of one
myth right out of the gate I remember a
long time ago a friend of mine had a
[ __ ] landscaping business and he
already had a truck and he went out he
bought this giant [ __ ] you know one
of those things with the dual wheels on
the back and this [ __ ] giant better
you put cattle in it right and I was
like holy [ __ ] man how much does that
thing cost and you know it's like the
80s it cost like 25 grand which is
a lot of [ __ ] money back then right
for a truck you know like ten grand one
you pay they twenty five thirty grand of
some [ __ ] right that was like holy [ __ ]
man you can afford that he was like
that's what a lot of dopes say and they
think it is a write-off but what they
think is is that they can write $30,000
off of their taxes what you you can't
what you can do is you can write off
it's a write-off as far as that 30 grand
that you just spent on that truck is
untack scible all right it's sitting in
whatever you made that money you made 30
grand if it's just sitting there and you
don't put it back into play as far as
reinvesting into your business the
government will tax you at the end of
the year you know on that 30 grand and
let's say you're in like a [ __ ] I
whatever
20 percent tax bracket that you'd you'd
have to give the government [ __ ] six
grand right that's it so the people
morons think oh I get to write 32 in the
end of the year if I owed 40 grand in
taxes and I bought a $30,000 truck I get
to take $30,000 off of my taxes you
wouldn't you just be able to knock off
six grand right you're not even knocking
it off you're just not getting taxed on
that does that make sense probably
doesn't cuz I explained it so anyways
when you have your own business what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
come up with as many [ __ ] right offs
as you possibly can many is expenses
everything you possibly can to lower
your your basic your whatever your
income as far as what is gonna be
taxable so say you made [ __ ] a
hundred grand
alright you grossed a hundred grand the
net is what you're left with after your
expenses you try to [ __ ] come up with
as many goddamn expenses as you can to
get that hundred grand as far down as
zero as possible ideally you wouldn't
want to pay any [ __ ] taxes as far as
these people look but the bottom line is
you can only do it so much and if you
write off too much the IRS is going to
show up and be like what's this [ __ ]
you know 60 grand for
[ __ ] cheeseburgers blah blah blah you
tried to write off you're gonna get
busted alright so what these [ __ ]
super-rich people do is the first thing
they do is they get the [ __ ] money
out of the out of the out of the country
because the IRS is jurisdiction doesn't
go beyond the borders so what they do is
they just create a company that doesn't
exist it's just it's just on paper right
to say you make a hundred million
dollars right what you do is you go to a
country that doesn't give a [ __ ] about
America and let you use it as a tax
shelter you just come up with some
incorporated thing like who gives a [ __ ]
Inc right and then you just have that
company bill your company a consulting
fee for a hundred million dollars or
whatever the for whatever of the 100
billion 30 40 50 whatever you don't want
to pay taxes on whatever you whatever
and then you write a check to that
company that doesn't exist that's really
you and then you send it out so now it's
out of the [ __ ] country and then what
they do is they open up like ten other
these [ __ ] shell companies and they
have those other companies build the
first company and then the third one
builds the second one the fourth one
billing it's just gone the money's
[ __ ] gone now the IRS can come at you
be what the [ __ ] did you pay somebody a
hundred million dollars consulting fee
and then you're telling me you paid
somebody a hundred million dollars is a
consulting fee and then you just look at
him and go yes and evidently there's
nothing they can [ __ ] do about it so
then I was algo alright so now it's out
of the country and then this it's in
this other country how the [ __ ] do you
protect it and I think and he goes well
you those countries where these tax
shelters are they're in on the scam so
you just kick them ten percent of the
hundred million you give them ten years
[ __ ] whatever you get negotiate will
just make it easy here's ten million
bucks so I you know I'll give you ten
million rather than the given the
government [ __ ] 50 55 60 million at
100 million I'm still [ __ ] up forty
five million all right
so then I was like alright so now how do
you get the money back
because if you know you bring the money
back you sticking to the bank they're
gonna consider that earned income like
where the [ __ ] did you get it and this
guy was like they they bring it back
into the country in the form of a loan
loans aren't taxable right like if you
get a [ __ ] loan cuz you're already
paying interest on it everything they
don't tax you so they just bring it back
in the form of a loan whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do I want to buy a ten
million dollar house you have this shell
company that's ten times removed from
the one that you paid from the
consulting fee right and they can't
follow the paper trail because it's in a
different country right you just bring
it back into the country in the form of
a loan and then you go buy a [ __ ]
house and I guess I don't know you
pretend to make payments or the loan is
forgiven by the shell company that's
still you I know I just glossed over
that and if anybody has more information
on it I find it absolutely fascinating
there's all there's other ones they just
pretend that that's their main business
that shell company so they just act like
it's doing the I don't know that that's
that's as far as I can remember that
what he told me and I found that [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] fascinating because
at the end of the [ __ ] day as far as
what they're doing I know they're
[ __ ] over you and me because you know
the school systems go down the [ __ ]
because they don't enough money there's
a lot of potholes there's all kinds of
stuff you can't take care of homeless
people you can't build another gleaming
structure for a [ __ ] sports team
whatever the [ __ ] it is the end of the
day is [ __ ] up as that is these people
who are criminals they're stealing from
other criminals as far as my conspiracy
theory goes the IRS is just a bunch of
[ __ ] crooks anyway so I mean they
it's kind of fascinating watching these
two giant powerful entities [ __ ] with
each other you know meanwhile you know
I'm in the cross hairs you're on the
cross hairs and we're all paying Elvis
taxes
and there goes Hillary Clinton screaming
in some Baptist Church is she talking
about that [ __ ]
of course she isn't because when you
bring the [ __ ] money back in you just
don't bring it in and go out by yourself
you [ __ ] Ferrari California what you
do is I mean you do do that but what
else what you also do is you walk around
nice wad of cash and you go oh hey Chief
of Police oh look at that birdie over
there and as he looks over your stuff a
[ __ ] wad of cash in his pocket you
know and then all oh is it an election
year yeah let me get a take two million
on Trump
give me 2.5 on Hillary and [ __ ] it give
me 500 grand on Bernie Sanders
what do you mean he's not taking any
money from guys like me oh is that right
yeah well you know whatever he won't get
in and if he does you know give three
million to well you know silenced them
that's what the [ __ ] they do and that's
and that's how they they you know I
don't I'm convinced to that I'm
convinced as far as like stand-up comedy
goes you know why they're always given a
[ __ ] is because we stand up comedians
just organized okay and we donated to
the campaign's of people running from to
the Democratic and the Republican
parties right and then we bought a
little ad time on CNN and on Fox News
and all these major networks if we did
that you'd never see another comedian
getting in trouble for doing a [ __ ]
Caitlyn Jenner joke anyways if anybody
has any more information on that or they
can talk about I I don't like if it's
really dry I just like I'm fascinated
with people that do [ __ ] like that and
then they go to bed knowing what the
[ __ ] they're doing and they got to be
thinking at some point like the Wolves
got to be coming to the door at some
point hang on one second I got an answer
this all right some PAC of course I
completely forget what the [ __ ] I where
I ended off but what I really learned
when I was you know listening to this
lawyer telling me all this [ __ ] oh I
know I say no balls that that takes to
go to bed at night knowing at any point
like oh so the [ __ ] feds are gonna
kick in your [ __ ] door but I think
that these guys are like too small
and when you watch like American greed
what I noticed when I watched them all
of their [ __ ] was within the borders
of the United States which you just I
mean if you I guess if you're too dumb
to know you don't realize you're not
gonna get away with it forever but like
once I after talking to this guy it just
seems like anybody who just tries to
have their entire illegal entity within
the borders of one country is you just
on borrowed time so I think when you
watch American greed what you're really
seeing is is the hacks of you know you
always these [ __ ] idiots they buy a
house they get all these [ __ ] cars
and they have some strippers come over
oh my [ __ ] laptop oh that was a
laptop hitting hardwood floors come on
come on baby come on come around you're
all right hang in there help is on the
way [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] Steve
Jobs is laughing somewhere right now
he's laughing at me because I got to
give him money and he also know there's
gonna be another little kids gonna put
it together all right in saved it's
saved so anyways uh let's read a little
bit of [ __ ] ads [ __ ] here before my
screen goes dark I hang on a second I
find that [ __ ] I find it I find all that
stuff [ __ ] amazing it's really really
interesting if you just remove yourself
from it the humanity of it or whatever
and all the people that it's affecting
and kids not getting better schoolbooks
and [ __ ] if you just look at the [ __ ]
game that's going on it's really [ __ ]
interesting all right oh [ __ ] we got
somebody know him we got somebody new
this is Joe Rogan's company the great
Joe Rogan from the Joe Rogan experience
podcast he might recognize him from gee
I don't know the first 200 UFC
pay-per-views one of the best stand-up
comics I've ever seen all right here's
this company on it on it is a health and
wellness company focused on inspiring
peak performance through unique products
and actionable information I can already
tell you this is written too
smartly so I'm gonna [ __ ] this up with
strategy from leading professional
athletes and medical practitioners on it
has focused on creating earth grown
nutrient based supplements and foods as
well as unconventional fitness equipment
all based on the latest science research
unconventional Fitness you got like the
leg curl thing going the other way you
break your [ __ ] knees did on it
believes that supplementing your diet
and with earth grown ingredients
challenging your body with innovative
fitness methods and supporting cognitive
functions of the brain are all pieces to
the complete to the complete approach to
wellness they call total human Optim
optimization please don't write that
word again I'll [ __ ] it up find out more
at onit comm slash bill onn i t-dot-com
slash bill alpha brain instant is a
delicious all-natural stimulant free
drink mix that helps support memory
focus and processing speed Joe you got
anything here to help somebody read out
loud better go to on at.com slash bill
to get a free trial of alpha brain
instant I know somebody using this Sh is
actually saying it's the [ __ ] alpha
brain instant is a delicious I already
said this right all natural stimulant
free drinks that help support memory
focus and processing speed I already
said this I need this [ __ ]
I need cases of this stuff to
double-blind randomized
placebo-controlled studies conducted by
the boston center for memory showed that
subjects taking alpha brain demonstrated
a significant improvement in areas of an
executive function verbal memory and
processing speed what are you waiting
for you got nothing to lose in a serious
edge to gain ignite your brain with
alpha instant try it try it for free at
on at.com slash bill now that's o n n i
t-dot-com slash built right free today
jesus christ i had a [ __ ] brain cramp
just trying to read that you know
I like shakes I like a delicious shake
that comes from the earth you know it
helps me remember where I put the
[ __ ] stirrer for it alright blue
apron everybody you need you need to
know how to cook
unless you're filthy rich unless you got
a [ __ ] shell company right not only
do you need to feel like you know your
way around a kitchen but cooking at home
means eating healthier and saving money
instant instead of ordering expensive
take out again and becoming a fat [ __ ]
who's kidding who but where do you start
blue apron has you covered yeah you
don't start with a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich you want to hit the
ground running for less than $10 per
meal blue apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients you need to create
home-cooked meals just follow the easy
step-by-step instructions each meal can
be prepared in 40 minutes or less no
overwhelming trips to the grocery store
no more sad takeout naw no matter your
dietary preferences blue apron makes it
a breeze to discover and prepare dishes
like steak and eggs with kimchi fried
rice I would chicken khao SOI soup
locked in crispy wonton noodles I'd wait
fun that one spiced catfish with pee Li
style rice and creamy saffron aioli I
would eat that cauliflower that looks
like manure many Erie meu ni e re and
it's underlined in red so it wasn't
spelled correctly or it's such a brand
new [ __ ] word I wouldn't eat it
delicious and good for you right now
it's made out of a rock they got from
[ __ ] mas right now you can get your
first two meals for free at blue apron
calm slash bird that's blue apron calm
slash / high blue apron calm a better
way to cook alright how many more of
these [ __ ] things do I have alright
we're going to and - then all right
you guys are you already listening to
[ __ ] two of these let's get back to
the podcast shall we alright um oh jesus
oh Jesus I got to bring it up my Boston
Bruins unfortunately after a big big win
over the Detroit Red Wings I got beat
down by Ottawa six to one
and we're out of it you know it's funny
did we beat Detroit the game before and
then because we lost Detroit get in and
do you know that was actually a certain
amount of [ __ ] Red Wing fans that
were actually talking [ __ ] the smart
ones but going hey thanks for losing and
then the other ones like we've been in
the playoffs yeah it's impressive but
this year you backed in like a [ __ ] you
went in as first I don't know what your
[ __ ] I mean because a team that you
couldn't even beat when it count two
days before you know who [ __ ]
manhandled you I don't know what you're
excited about you know you like the fat
chick who got you know [ __ ] ass to
the prompt you know yeah you all exceed
this you just wanted to be there who's
kidding no you're there for the [ __ ]
buffet and then you going home crying
that's what I'm predicting for Detroit
your makeups gonna be running by Game
three of the first series I'm [ __ ]
with you I I have no hate for anybody
that's in the playoffs this year I think
I'm gonna want man I've always liked
Detroit because when I was growing up
they never won [ __ ]
the big thing is they hadn't wanted
since 1955 with Gordie Howe and they
were in the middle of a 40-year drought
before they got a team around Yzerman
enough man that was what great times
watching hockey they [ __ ] Avalanche
Red Wings [ __ ] rivalry that was the
best it was the first time when I lived
in LA and the games came home at five
and I totally got back into hockey you
know I was original six oh he's the best
I'm sorry but could you order here so so
this year I think in the East I'm gonna
I'm gonna root I'm gonna root for two
[ __ ] teams this year in the east and
the West I'm rooting for the Capitals to
push through to get to the finals and as
much as I like the kings and the
Blackhawks just to switch it up I'd love
to see the Dallas Stars or the st. Louis
Blues you know somebody different you
know st. Louis Blues whose kid net fans
have been waiting for [ __ ] ever they
have been in a league they're part of
the expansion six
in 1967 all right
the NHL was a six team league before
that right after the depression there
was a lot of people that I didn't
realize this either there was a there
was a bunch of other teams not a bunch
but there was like at least four other
[ __ ] teams or something that all
folded after the the depression and the
six that survived then became known as
the original six so in 1967 six teams
came in okay off the top of my head
let's see there was the Flyers the
Penguins the North Stars
you know Jesus the California golden
seals man I used to know this off top of
my head wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait Capitals didn't come in until
the early 70s [ __ ] make st. Louis Blues
Jesus Christ just brought him up one
more one more
was it a Seattle team Cleveland Barons
that's what the [ __ ] golden seals
became didn't they oh the [ __ ] LA
Kings
yeah the LA Kings way the [ __ ] out there
and that was funny when for the golden
seals like folded or wear to Cleveland
they went to Cleveland just like the
dreams of all the sports fans there they
did they just [ __ ] died a slow
miserable death and like that franchise
just died out nobody bought it and went
nowhere it just went to Cleveland and
[ __ ] died so for the longest time the
only game in town out [ __ ] West was
the Kings every [ __ ] road trip they
had was like at least a three for our
[ __ ] flight Denver didn't have a team
Vancouver didn't have a team Edmonton
Calgary they nothing they were just out
there by themselves you know basically
[ __ ] whatever actresses couldn't bang
a Los Angeles Dodger or in LA ramp
that's basically they got sloppy thirds
that's what was going on so anyways yeah
we lost so graduations to the four
and the [ __ ] Red Wings there was two
spots left into three teams vying for it
and we didn't get in and like clockwork
the day after we don't get in what
Boston sports writer who doesn't watch
hockey do you think will piled on
immediately and as always calls for the
wrong head to be chopped off good old
Dan Shaughnessy the noodle headed [ __ ]
himself who doesn't watch hockey doesn't
like hockey chimes in something's got to
be done it's time based on what Dan all
the hockey you never [ __ ] watch
Claude Julien this was actually one of
his finest coaching performances of the
year of I mean of his career they traded
the entire [ __ ] team away basically
they truly it was what they got rid of
over the last few years Tyler Seguin
Johnny Boychuk Dougie [ __ ] fresh
they're [ __ ] Milan Lucic it was just
I was like we got nothing
we got nothing left I Mountain Logan
Marshawn we got Bergy was still had
Chara char was old and now but basically
whose kid knew anybody [ __ ] watch his
hockey looked at the Bruins it was like
you know what this is a rebuilding year
and all the way up to like mid-march
Clojure lien had this this rebuilding
year team was a third seat everybody was
bunched together we had a bad patch you
know went out west tough [ __ ] run we
lost some games and next thing you know
we were fighting for the playoff lives
as they say and we didn't win I mean I
mean I don't know and you get I would
get if anybody's heads gonna get chopped
off you chopped the head off whoever
made all those [ __ ] trades but you
know the bottom line is the guy who made
the first half of those already got his
head chopped off and then he got was at
Michael Connell you got to give this guy
a chance right you can't just go one and
done [ __ ] up with that B they just
came cloture lis in a [ __ ] watch for
having the most Vic the most wins ever
of any Bruins coach he got us our first
[ __ ] Stanley Cup in like
what was it almost 40 years and then
what a couple years later he doesnot a
coach hockey anymore why is it time Dan
Shaughnessy why is it time because it's
too early in the baseball season you got
nothing to write about this guy's
forever calling for somebody's head you
know what Dan you know I think it's time
for you to do it's time for you to stop
writing about hockey or maybe watching
maybe [ __ ] five games of the goddamn
season unfuckable that guy I swear to
god it at the end of the day I think
he's from New York City the way he just
tries to pull apart [ __ ] teams it's
unbelievable you know what I mean he's
like somebody wants some mob guys gumar
that they end up having a whack cuz she
can't keep her [ __ ] mouth shut
oh Jesus bill go easy on the guy he's
just trying to sell some [ __ ] hey I
don't really hate Dan Shaughnessy I
don't know the guy but I can tell you
right now
he's one of the few people that looks
less athletic than me anywho as I as I
was talking about earlier I've been
doing the whole [ __ ] clean living
thing since I got back from yet another
lost bachelor party weekend slash
stand-up dates run with with my buddies
their furs E and bartnick and so this
whole week no booze no porn no cigars
nothing I got the cigar thing I got that
thing on on [ __ ] lockdown I don't
have him in my house I think about do I
don't think about doing it as much and I
only had one cigar in March and I'm
going to try to just have one this month
although look I'm thinking about only
having one and then I'm also thinking
about having a [ __ ] cigar night over
here I might do that because I have like
[ __ ] I don't know about ten cigar
friends unless you smoke cigars you
don't know what that means but that's
just people that call a I'm gonna smoke
you want to come by right so all of a
sudden I have ten opportunities a month
people call me a come on man come by and
smoke mines
Kenickie know you smoked in like seven
eight nine ten of them so I'm gonna
invite all of them over to my house the
same [ __ ] night and I'll smoke one
cigar with all ten of them rather than
smoking one each with ten individuals
how does that math work right then I'll
create a shell company so anyways so I
bought this time magazine on watching
internet porn and how it's [ __ ] up
kids like they're you know the amount of
[ __ ] that they see before they even get
their first [ __ ] hand job it turns
him into like these [ __ ] sociopaths
and I got to admit reading some of the
articles like I could relate to a lot of
this [ __ ] that was going on so I'm
really just gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna try
to stop that cold turkey you know I
gotta stop looking at that [ __ ] I'm
sorry
see this clean listen what clean living
does for you 10:30 at night I'm [ __ ]
yawning I'm ready to go bed right now
get my [ __ ] Jam jams and here in here
I am supposed to be there for you you
guys are sitting there at work the last
[ __ ] thing you need you probably
already had a doughnut you're gonna sit
a sugar crash here in a minute and Here
I am yawning on ya so what else can I
talk about here oh yeah clean living if
you're trying to have some clean living
do not watch the Lemmy documentary which
I just watched for the second time makes
you want to have a couple of drinks cuz
you like look how long that guy [ __ ]
lifts all the [ __ ] that he did you know
[ __ ] yeah they're good alright 39
minutes in I can do the last 21 minutes
here without yawning here we go here we
go alright by the way I don't for people
out there you know I mentioned some of
the helicopters [ __ ] I did I did I tell
you I finally did that's that solo
flight that I wanted to do from Long
Beach and I went through the bravo
airspace with the planes taken off over
you you know and LAX came right around
looked at the house flew over the
[ __ ] house that they the horse's head
from Godfather right down sunset over to
El Monte and then back to oh I did tell
you that because that's when I saw the
old guy fall off the [ __ ]
could scooter I'm sorry I thought I
didn't think that I told you that one I
was just thinking about that [ __ ] the
other day and course my [ __ ]
headphones go out what they would have
[ __ ] on I knew it I [ __ ] knew it I
knew that was gonna happen so anyways I
was at the Comedy Store on Saturday
night and I was trying out this this new
chunk that I've been [ __ ] with for
the last couple of months and I finally
got it down I said it it's perfect as I
could say and of course I didn't I
didn't [ __ ] and in tape of course I
didn't tape why would I take that would
have been the smart thing to do but
whatever I said it so I'll get it I'll
get it back and I felt [ __ ] great
about it and then today I got text
messages from two different comedians
telling me that they love the new [ __ ]
that I was doing it just I just made my
[ __ ] day so I'm really excited about
getting that [ __ ] together cuz I want to
do another special this year and I got
some stuff in my act that's funny but I
just feel like the topics have been done
before so I'm gonna try to like you know
you know push that [ __ ] to the wayside
maybe that'll just be on the the some of
those topics will just be on like the
when I released the vinyl of the Madison
Square Garden Show I'll just keep them
on that one there'll be some extra joke
so it won't be the same material I don't
know I'm just excited about the the next
few months how that shit's gonna turn up
but uh before I get into the questions
this week everybody I have to give a
shout-out to rogue fitness who evidently
was listening to the podcast I was
breaking their balls you know I'm making
a gym I'm paying somebody to build a gym
for me out my garage a little gym there
in the back and I got all my [ __ ]
through rogue fitness they just had the
best [ __ ] out there and I was just
joking with them that uh you know how
dare you not to send me free [ __ ] I
didn't even ask him for I just
immediately came on the podcast breaking
their [ __ ] balls and they listened to
the one where there was me and Nia Nia
told me to get the regular looking
weights just the ones that look like
iron or whatever and I wanted the I
wanted the colorful ones and she thought
that they were corny so all of a sudden
I just got this shipment of these
colorful weights and I was laughing
going
man I must have [ __ ] it up I got the
colorful ones so I wrote them trying to
ask how to send it back and they said no
we listen to the podcast they sent me
some free wait and they sent me a
t-shirt sigh you know rogue fitness I
was [ __ ] around you didn't have to do
that
you guys are solid man and I'm I can't
wait to you know you sure your equipment
cuz it's great made in the USA all good
stuff oh look who's here
the busybody the lovely Nia did you get
some Thai food yeah did you grab a mic
what do you want to eat do you want to
eat
I got another 17 minutes here 17 minutes
the mics are in the closet
why don't you want you to sit down and
help me through with the questions why
do i hook it up because I am I'm
actively doing the podcast right now
actively oh Jesus
you know it'd be gonna be in a mood like
that oh Jesus
what's that he just walked out on me
anyways alright well I'm gonna start
reading the first one then you don't
care alright oh by the way you know
something I was taking my dog out for a
walk today you know we were walking up
into the park there and this is before
she puked and I decided to turn around
and come home she's out of nowhere she
started yakking
made me feel bad I was like Jesus hope
it wasn't something I did it wasn't hot
out or anything
well another [ __ ] group of people
come up the second they get into the
into the park they just [ __ ] don't
say what Parker they get in the [ __ ]
Park and they [ __ ] take the leashes
off the [ __ ] dogs come right up to my
dog it's like my dog isn't my dog my dog
is Gore's
other dogs it chills and then like when
you are bugging my dog it doesn't go it
never has see hey can you do me a favor
can you knock it off it immediately just
grabs you like remember Friday the 13th
when Jason was under the cot and grabbed
that dude's head and reached up I guess
it was the chicken the
I met a dog tonight who just didn't like
anybody and I but I realized quickly
what it was his owner was holding him
and any time anyone came towards the
owner like oh hey oh what a cute dog the
dog would start growling and I and it's
so funny because he said to one of the
people Oh Pat him and I'm like no your
dog isn't doesn't want to be pet it
growls at everybody and I think the dog
was protecting the owner so anytime you
know like I said anyone came towards him
he started growling right he was so
clueless that he was like oh he's mine
just pet him I'm like no no you can't
pet the dog if it's growling at people I
can't judge him our dogs are psycho dog
went to bite me like it actually kind of
like put its its its it went to buy you
like it walked across the [ __ ] room
oh I went over there like that it put
its its put my finger in between its
teeth and didn't chop down little dog I
was a but yes but it was a biting
behavior so little by little dogs with
people they'd be riding around in
convertibles you know like a Corvette or
some [ __ ] all right leave in 11 minutes
all right so you wanna do one one
question yeah all right job
hey Billy beret I were I'm working part
time job and I have a problem let me see
if there's a relationship one here
why can't open all right can I not be
involved in the the job line well I just
feel like I always give the guy advice
well maybe it's time to shake it up a
little bit that's nice trying to do have
you give some lady advice on some
relationship huh oh god you're gonna go
on a feminist rant here you know women
can answer other [ __ ] questions
doesn't have to do with relationships
hey you know I'm trying to give you a
nice softball here trying to lob it over
the [ __ ] softball anything she's
rolling your head here we go when all
reality showing me there all right I'm
working a part-time job and I have a
problem related to it
alright the job is that work at a
[ __ ] ice cream it's at an ice cream
place in my town and the second time I
work
they are a while back I had a god-awful
shift I didn't have all the kinks of the
job worked yet and I was working with
someone I didn't know which made me more
nervous the night quickly became but you
know this word Kafka esque
a raid whose gasps who's that no he's a
writer
is he a philosopher I already have a
particular political view I think he
died in a boating accident whatever was
Kafka asked Joseph Kafka I think he's
one of those ancestors JLo no before she
goes on tour I'm not Google can we just
read the [ __ ] question all right the
night quickly became a Kafka s Parade of
horrific errors I screwed up orders
stock things wrong etc and by the end of
the night my coworker was audibly and
visibly disgusted with me and she should
have been Shiraz Kafka okay sorry
German language writer of novels and
short stories
who is oh my god he died the day after
my birthday and therein lies the tragedy
I was gonna say surreal I was right yes
mm-hmm this is not entertaining sorry
Suzanne entertaining for people Kafka
asked elements often appear in
existential works but the term has
transcended the literary realm to apply
to real life occurrences in situations
that are incomprehensibly complex
bizarre or illogical there we go Franz
Kafka all right okay all right so the
ladies of the lady is was upset with
them and he's saying you know audibly
and visibly disgusted with me and she
should have been okay she's in college
and I'm in high school so luckily I
never had to work with her again after
the summer was over and she went back to
her classes but even as recently as
Spring Break I've heard she's still
talking
about me oh you heard this all the way
bet she's at some college yeah how did
you hear that yeah they're all on the
Facebook Oh
grandpa I love saying you guys taken the
Molly
no you wouldn't you wouldn't no Molly if
you were the grandpa really Molly the
ecstasy whatever just an old guy Thanks
yeah that was my dad when he used to get
mad at my sister Christ is she on that
Internet she on that Internet it's
almost summer again and I'm almost
definitely going to have to face her if
I work regularly if I do I know for a
fact I'll [ __ ] things up immediately
purely from anxiety dude you should be
like the [ __ ] older wiser guy
crushing it and then you [ __ ] bang
her confidence my friend wait what what
do you mean bang her it's all there why
don't you what it's all there you can
make a revolt you get two straws you
know what because she's the older woman
right and she has to be tamed by getting
that dick is that what it is I didn't
say that yeah you basically did because
your life is like a [ __ ] movie from
the 1920s bill where the guy is slapping
the woman around like get it together
see and she says no no he completely
made-up cosmetics this is like one of
those coming-of-age movies worn that
begin beginning the Nerds look you'll
walk away from me the nerd is looking at
the cheerleader she's dating the
impossible dick with the blood wavy hair
right somebody does a [ __ ] triple
lindy Jesus Christ I went sideways huh
the [ __ ] just happened there listen cuz
I'm not gonna be able to get awarded in
defense of what I was saying right he
makes an ass out of himself in front of
this you know this older [ __ ] broad
all right see this isn't sexist they
come back you're a little older a little
wiser right you're a year older you're
still growing you filled out a little
bit right all of a sudden you're
crushing it you make it a [ __ ] couple
banana splits and a smoothie all at the
same time then she's just like wow this
is
the man that I left the year you know
the year before all of a sudden you guys
are working closely you know ice cream
is always romantic I'm telling this kid
to [ __ ] shake it off because if I
don't work often I could lose my job as
we've got more employees than we need
and I really have a great set up now
that I've learned that the work is easy
I basically picked my own hours and my
bosses by far the sweetest racist
homophobe I've ever met in my life
any ideas besides the obvious murder he
said your stand-up is killer I hope I
can see perform some time yeah dude you
got it you got to grow a dick here man
you're the [ __ ] man you've been there
for a year you know what's going on just
be like I'm not just what do you do you
have a crush on this woman if she's not
gonna [ __ ] you then what do you care
what she thinks is that bad man yes to
do it just have confidence in yourself
and do the job also this is this is a
high school person that's writing in
this is somebody who's making ice cream
cones and he's scared out of his mind
about some woman who's not easy and he's
not even [ __ ] he doesn't want to ask
her out what is the problem she's gonna
yell at you about the way you put the
[ __ ] cherry job you know worried
about how he's gonna perceive you're
always going to be at that age where you
know every little thing you know means
disaster and the bigger picture Oh
pastor fising a little bit yeah I think
you're worried a little too much about
nothing just do your job
do your thing don't even worry about it
and there's plenty of other jobs out
there by the way you should just be
totally cocky when she comes in ice
cream all right weed [ __ ] or Nothing
Jesus Christ pushing all the chips and
this is the World Series of Poker all
right hey there Billy Boy I'm a new
listener to your podcast
but a longtime fan of you stand up I was
wondering if you could help me out with
a dilemma I'm facing so my weed dealer
put the moves on me my last time I was
at her place nothing came of it but I
could tell she was trying to get me to
[ __ ] her until now I thought it was
weird that she began to sell me pot for
practically nothing wow she's cool and
I've hung out with her at her place many
times to just smoke weed just just as
well I'm single so I have no problem
getting some strange [ __ ] that falls
into my lap the problem is that she's a
very heavy broad and completely
unattractive Oh JJ's but she sells the
best weed in the area dude this is
[ __ ] this has all the makings of the
great first 10 pages of a script we've
established who the characters are oh
yeah super you know that guys just want
to [ __ ] you women know that you use it
to your advantage to get [ __ ] and then
when we admit that that's what we want
to do you do oh my god I really wish
someone would tell the story about a guy
who's getting a throne [ __ ] left and
right and doesn't know what to do with
it it's like a coming-of-age and I'm
sure he's also fighting with his friends
a little bit about like what dorm and
estate and it was just hilarious he's
got this heavy broad that he's not
attracted to whose [ __ ] weed dealer
yeah she's got the best weed he knows he
wants she wants to [ __ ] him what was the
rest of the story does he want you this
is a [ __ ] come on Seth Rogen would crush
this you are Rayna you know what you
hungry you're like him when that
Snickers commercial Rogen would write a
phenomenal transcendent script that
Jonah Hill would act out and it would
just be like wow it's like what is wrong
with you I like all of those people and
I like those movies you don't like Hot
Tub Time Machine to be chubby and
awkward and not know what
your life Oh what are you a being a jerk
you being a jerk yeah yeah hungry I'm
pologize too okay yeah you are you're a
little out of sorts here okay all right
you know you're burning bridges in this
town sweetie let me tell you something
those bridges don't come back but she
sells the best weed in the area I don't
want right I don't want to not [ __ ] her
and then ever cut me off but at the same
time I feel that I if I do [ __ ] her then
I'm no better than an addicted crack
[ __ ] doing a line off some fat guys
dick so guess what when it comes down to
it do I [ __ ] my ugly drug dealer for
good cheap or do I just or do I just
find a new dealer with super herb and
pay more money thanks hope all is well
with you ginger [ __ ] ginger [ __ ] have
you ever heard the expression don't [ __ ]
where you eat yeah don't [ __ ] your weed
dealer yeah don't just don't [ __ ] her
this is a business relationship keep it
business should he like lie and start
talking about how he has a girlfriend no
just buy weed from her and like just let
it be business yes stop smoking with her
and also like I mean maybe she's
desperate for your [ __ ] but maybe you're
like reading into it she might be trying
to [ __ ] you and the next dude so she's
giving she's she's a drug dealer she's
hustling she's hustling for like
customers she's hustling for dick like
don't get excited
you know there's only one bra so you
think
yeah but she's giving it away for next
to nothing if she does that she's not
gonna make any money true she's making
it in other ways I don't know I feel
like just don't [ __ ] your weed dealer
that just sounds like a disaster written
all over it or get yourself a really
good connect now have that in your back
pocket so if you do decides the only
reason why you would [ __ ] your weed
dealer is if you actually want to [ __ ]
her not because you're so desperate for
the best we'd ever have you really had
the best weed in like your entire say
probably not so calm down don't got a
dealer uh-huh
I mean you know you kind of into their
having you're not just going hey can I
get a hit off that when you [ __ ]
going there
week after week to the point that the
dealers are a dime a dozen though
there's it's not like it is specialty
but I'm just saying this [ __ ] chick
is the Beast he's buying so much weed
off of she's developing feelings for
she's not
he might be cute a little crush but like
it's not that see it's my point is it's
not that serious
don't [ __ ] your weed dealer unless you
want to have a problem with your weed
dealer and you do we dealer wants to
[ __ ] one of her customers of course I
completely believe it I'm just saying
just don't don't go there it's not worth
it that's my bottom line she's usually
not this grumpy you guys alright grumpy
old boyfriend Tex wife Oh Billy Cheez
balls
I just [ __ ] make up names for me okay
alright very happily married for 25
years to the hottest wife and mother of
our three sons she's in spectacular
shape and beautiful while on vacation in
Palm Springs right escaped herself in
shape
yeah we're visual animals we're visual
animals I know there's a reason why all
those gay guys are walking around with
six-packs because they know what they're
trying to attract don't you think all
those gay guys want to go to the gym
that much they have to if they don't
that's the end of the dick train and
they know it they know it so anyways
while on vacation in Palm Springs I
caught a glimpse of her phone screen and
saw a text from Pb Pb was asking how's
the weather so I asked her who PB is
after a little persuasion she replied
it's Dave dave is a boyfriend from her
high school years and he is a former
fiance this is awful
she promised it was nothing I asked if
they've seen each other of him
underneath a different name though yes
that's pretty suspect when you have the
person's name saved under a alias PB was
PB man wait penis brilliant brilliant
penis she's dyslexic penis babe
[Music]
[ __ ] banger it was a capital P and then
a lowercase B I don't know why he did it
alright if you guys have any suggestions
what PBS stands for come on that's what
social media is all about because she
promised it was nothing I asked if if
they had seen each other or slept
together she said no I believe her okay
Jesus
it's a former CF fiance does he mean now
I guess now well maybe I just want to
believe her she's otherwise a very
honest person well I sent Dave a text
and here's what I said Oh beautiful I'm
only gonna say this once
you're nothing but a sleazy [ __ ]
you've crossed the line of decency go
[ __ ] yourself
or better yet go choke to death on some
poor somebody's dick wait wait it's a
it's a homophobic he was upset you know
never communicate with my wife capital
letters ever if you pursue her in any
way I'll cut you dick off with a rusty
saw-blade
and shove it down your throat I hope
you're getting the message hear his
reply understood this is the last text
name and number deleted my question to
you is was I harsh enough with T and I'm
not sure what to do with about my wife
she deleted him from our context and she
said she has no need to ever communicate
with him again what are your thoughts I
think
need to let it be then I mean I that was
I have to say that was masterful that
text that he sent to PB aka Dave I think
he got the message with that one now
what do you think so do you think she
banged him no she's probably sitting
flirting borderline inappropriate text
messages maybe years those beautiful of
the day I took you to prom like that
time [ __ ] why you I went a little
further than that I don't [ __ ] know
i if it were you bill burr you probably
would have said like do you know how you
are you probably would have said some
inappropriate [ __ ] over text I mean
that's right away how do I get to the
texting to us we this way and how
texting words advice from a for a fellow
ginger fellow ginger from Finland here I
have a decision to make and would
appreciate some advice from a wise and
experienced man like you ever since I
was a kid oh you've just every [ __ ]
thing ever since I was a kid I've wanted
to be an airline pilot I'm 19 years old
and I'm graduating from high school in
December yes here we finish high school
later I was just gonna say is that when
they graduate from high school and
Finland yeah later than you guys in
merica alright I have till the end of
the year to decide what I want to study
I've always had a plan after high school
I would want to go to a Flight Academy
and become a pilot
but now I've started to question if
that's what I really want to do for a
living living I mean an airline pilot is
an incredible job absolutely love flying
and we get to travel a bunch and see all
kinds of amazing places etc plus I would
get to the Sun every day without burning
my Nordic ultra pasty pasty skin the
captain makes six figures
which is plenty enough for me since I'm
not into money my only problem with
being a pilot is that I would never be
completely free meaning that for the
rest of my life working for some other
douchebag would would decide for me when
I can come to work and where I can fly
the idea of being tied up to a company
and having some [ __ ] making all the
decisions for me scares the [ __ ] out of
me when I'm older I want to be able to
do things on an impulse without asking
permission from some capital letters
other men also pilots but you're just
over there taking pictures of [ __ ] Nia
also pilots spent a lot of time away
from home and someday when I start a
family to have kids I want to spend as
much time as possible with them so that
could be a problem as well flying planes
for a living would be a dream job but it
would get in the way of my other dream
of being completely my own man and free
what do you think should I go study
something else no what you should do is
still be into the aviation thing you
just figure out a way to do what you
want to do within aviation
okay I will equate it to the job that I
have I am a stand-up comedian which
opens up all these doors into the
entertainment world which a lot of them
you think you want to run through until
you get to the other side and then you
realize what you're talking about is
like holy [ __ ] I thought I had the world
by the balls if I got this I thought I
would be the pimp and then you realize
that you're actually the [ __ ] so you
have to what I would do if I was you is
I would still go to flight school I
would learn how to fly and then what I
would do is rather than going flying for
some commercial airline there's got to
be some other cool [ __ ] that you can do
like flying for sightseeing tours you're
not into money right maybe you do that
maybe you end up having that business
and other people fly for you and you get
to fly around what other jobs are they
there's fighting forest fires that you
know you do that like helicopters and
planes and that type of [ __ ] sure yeah
listen just by being a pilot already you
got some sort of renegade spirit in you
so I'm sure there's plenty of [ __ ]
jobs that you can get
in aviation I think it pretty much any
job this there's a way to be in the
matrix and then there's a way to be
outside like you know he's a renegade
that one you know don't get tied down
with that guy you could definitely do it
right what do you think yes yeah so he
should still be a pilot dude you love to
fly it's what you want to do but you
know there's all kinds of [ __ ] you could
fly for [ __ ] airline make you money
and then leave and then go do something
else like start your own business I
don't know you're laughing at me right
nineteen he's got the whole war he's got
he's got the world by the [ __ ] short
his I was listening to a podcast from a
while back then you were [ __ ] on the
NFL having games in London he said those
games are huge things for us to European
football fans and believe it or not
there are tons of football fans here in
Europe the games always sellout and I
felt football sells out out there who
knows all right here's new who's the
last one stuttering here okay guess what
I just time-traveled in the podcast let
me give you a second to just wrap your
head around this because I know it's
always weird when this happens I
actually finished out the podcast with
the lovely Neil but the my [ __ ]
batteries wore out and I didn't even
notice we had a nice debate she [ __ ]
trashed me what are you gonna do so let
me I don't mean no way to pick up here I
got two more reads to do and I think I
have another question I'm not sure so
let me all right Dollar Shave Club
everybody I know this is [ __ ] weird
sorry to just slam your [ __ ] brain
against the inside of your skull there
all right doll the Shave Club it's
Monday morning not by the way that's why
sound a little more fresh no yawn and
for all free codes alright do always
shave club Joe dollarshaveclub.com has a
special offer for new members who join
today you'll get a free month of the
executive razor when you buy a tube of
DOC dick you have errs I got a still I'm
gonna say copy for their doctor cavies
easy shave butter
everybody hear that executive razor I
just pictured like you know you have the
dress shirt on with boxers and then you
dress socks with sock artists just
shaving with it
I'm gonna fire someone tonight all right
this is the first time they've ever done
something like this and once you try
dollarshaveclub.com you'll be you'll
become a proud member like millions of
others one reason is because they
deliver amazing razors right to your
door for a third of the price of what
greedy razor corporations charge that
means when you join DSC you can afford
to shave with a fresh blade anytime you
want which feels fantastic you'll get a
first class shape when you use the
executive blade without hurting your
wallet Wow
Martin Sheen you're looking at man or
didn't judge another man by the size of
it remember that that [ __ ] Michael
Douglas greed is good movie Wall Street
all right another reason is dr. can have
ez Z shave butter using it with the
executive makes the blade glide gently
for the smoothest shave ever dr.
Carver's shave butter isn't your average
shave cream it's a unique conditioning
formula with high-quality natural
ingredients leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth Jesus
Christ we got it how many times you can
see how smooth it is like a baby's ass
call to call to action and right now new
members who buy a tube of shave butter
get the executive raider
razor for free e they've never done this
before take advantage of it it's only
available by going to
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / bar
dollarshaveclub.com / / MV mt watches
alright it's been a few weeks since I
cracked open these sharp looking
movement watch but no it's been a couple
of months stop put words in my mouth
alright as promised the quality these
watches are there for an awesome price
in the style department the compliments
I get on this thing are really
unbelievable considering I don't wear it
now I'm wearing it
describe your watch well I'm wearing the
[ __ ] watch I always had because I'm a
grown-up and I can afford a watch
because I spent twenty four [ __ ]
years in strip malls I can actually
afford one but back in the day I'm gonna
redo this copy alright when I couldn't
afford a watch
I stayed in that broken bed and that
[ __ ] up cabin up and Chilkoot
Charlie's in Alaska I would have worn a
watch like this they would have been
like goddamn it this guy's a pro I hope
they gave him a good bed if you hadn't
had the chance to experience how a
movement will how a movement watch fits
around your wrist this is your chance
movement watch watches start at just 95
bucks it looks like a $700 watch I'm not
gonna lie to you see when movement cut
out the middleman with the huge big
brand markups the price of a stylish
watch finally got affordable imagine
that a watch with it to put department
store quality for a fraction of the
price movement has grown organically
purely by supporters like you so join
their more than 1 million social media
followers and get a movement watch today
now I'm go to mV mt watches calm / burn
and they'll give you 15% off your entire
purchase
that's m/v Mt Michael Victor Michael
tango watches dot-com / bar and there is
one quick more last one stamps comm
mailing and shipping our a routine part
of running your business and important
keeps your operations going but if
you're making constant trips to the post
office that's a routine you need to
change there's much more convenient way
and that stamps calm stamp stock brings
all the services of the post office
right to your desk buying print official
us posted using your own computer and
printer you'll never waste valuable time
going to the goddamn post office again
so you can focus on what really matters
trying to bang the chick in the cubicle
next to you and growing your business I
use stamps comm anytime I send out any
of my posters I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure it out so can you right now sign
up for stamp stop calm and use my last
name bur for this special offer for four
week trial plus one hundred and ten
dollar bonus offers that includes
postage and a digital scale scale don't
wait go to Stan's calm before you do
anything else click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Barbie you are our that stamps calm and
tubero Jesus Christ alright okay the
last question that I actually did with
the lovely Nia and now a [ __ ] wage
gap myth all did this spark a debate
Dyl dear Billie Beru I was one of the
fortunate and audience members of your
epic terrorist performance you crushed
it in my opinion thank you very much he
said the wage gap statistic
he said I wanted to bunk a myth for you
the wage gap statistic you know this is
thing right now that they say that a
woman gets paid less 79 cents less to do
the exact same job is a guy but you know
my opinion is [ __ ] up the job should
pay what you pay right so this guy says
the wage gap statistic that you hear
about all the time is simply the average
earnings of men and women working
full-time it does not take into account
different job positions hours worked for
different jobs it has nothing to do with
the same work it has nothing to do with
discrimination in 1963 the Supreme Court
passed the Equal Pay Act which makes it
illegal to pay different wages for the
same job if you still don't buy that
then consider this if a company could
legally play pay women less money do you
think those greedy [ __ ] would ever hire
a man some decent points there once I
pulled this wage gap threat thread a
whole bunch of other feminist myths
started to unravel but I just wanted to
shine a light on this topic well okay
let's you know I'll have to look all of
that up I never looked up the Equal Pay
Act but if they're still able to make
the numbers work then wouldn't that say
that guys get the better high-paying
jobs then then does it become that I'm
just asking alright that's what I would
guess so I don't know evidently I have
some reading to do and I think a lot of
feminists do to that just jump on the
bandwagon I'll look up the Equal Pay Act
I don't know who the [ __ ] knows I mean
one of the dumbest [ __ ] ways to get
somebody to listen to your goddamn
opinion is to just sit there and be like
you got it better than us your life is
[ __ ] easy that immediately puts the
other side going like you know an ass
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and your brassiere you
know my [ __ ] life's easy I just dealt
with this this and this you know it just
puts people into that mindset I don't
know if that whole [ __ ] yelling and
screaming and [ __ ] you know believe me
as a Yeller and a screamer I know it
doesn't make people listen to you it
just makes you people just go oh my god
I want to get away from this person or
that person's a [ __ ] lunatic that's
been my experience trying to convey
ideas
since I was a little orange headed child
I don't know what's going on okay at the
end of the day people should that the
job should pay what the job pays and the
best person should get it but sadly that
is never going to happen because there's
always going to be the boss's son
there's always going to be the hot chick
there's always going to be the racist
the homophobe the person who comes in
with the southern accent you're up north
or vice versa and somebody's mentally
still fighting the war or thinks other
people are stupid
you keep the only way to take the human
element out of it is to gradually slowly
but surely dumb down human beings make
everything automated and you slowly
replace them with free-thinking robots
which is basically what's going to
happen by free-thinking I mean they
agree with the upper 1% and not even the
upper 1% the upper 1% of the 1% that
doesn't even show up you know there's a
lot of you remember all the blue blood
money and everybody kind of knew how
much money they had and now they all say
that oh they gave away a lot
you know the Rockefellers are you know
their fortune isn't what it's worth they
used to be the Vanderbilts they're only
worth like seventy five million dollars
now I mean that's I don't know there's
all these stories out there that there's
families that are so [ __ ] big and
powerful they're above any sort of
boarders and they [ __ ] you know when
they travel by yacht it's only like it's
like their little Navy
and they just it's I love conspiracy
theory and they just float around they
pull up to the dock and the countries
just come out and give them bags of gold
and then they just disappear it's like
Waterworld except you know without the
you know I don't sip they still have all
the amenities because the world hasn't
flooded over yet does that make any
sense you know I think that's as good a
spot to stop as anything
my apologies for [ __ ] up the podcast
this week you guys have a nice couple of
[ __ ] days and can I end on some more
drum nerd [ __ ] I told you my drum
teachers taken me through that sting
album ten summers tails whatever that
has the great Vinnie Colaiuta on it and
how they played in all these odd times
but they wanted to imply 4/4 time and he
finally taught me on that seven days
which is in five which I love he finally
wrote out what he was doing on the
hi-hat which is basically he's playing
that it's for four against five he's
playing five underneath but he's
implying four in the hi-hat and after
all these [ __ ] years are trying to
figure out how to do it he finally he
just wrote out one line of it and now it
makes sense to me and it's basically on
the hi-hat I just still count in five
but you just count you know underneath
you if you listen to it you count one
two three four five one two three four
five foam to go one then that [ __ ]
[ __ ] but on top how it works for me is
you just you just I still count in five
I just you're thrown in he counted is
like eighth notes so one and two and
three and four and five and one and two
and three and four and five and the
first time through you accent one three
and five and the second time through you
accent two and four try that that's the
way I've been doing it now granted this
is massively filtered out from a
professional drummer to a stand-up
comedian who cannot read out loud
alright that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you on Thursday belcheck
you